plans for a more open and competitive
domestic be railway network was given
the green light after mepz negotiators
from the council shook hands on a deal
on the final pillar of the fourth
railway package it was tough the council
didn't want social obligations for the
member states second item was under
which circumstances the contract for the
new railway package can be awarded
directly so no public procurement but
direct award of the new railway contract
negotiations to improve Europe's railway
network have been laboring on for four
years one of the biggest headaches has
been how to change the way in which
public service contracts were awarded
under the deal competitive bidding will
now allow new operators onto the market
thereby breaking up old monopolies but
with an exception smaller member states
will still be able to award direct
contracts also on the table preventing
conflict of interest between rail
operators and infrastructure managers
better safeguards a train worker rights
and better access for high-speed rail
and for the consumer yeah bruh no pue
possibilità di shield como siempre
cuando se aprende scotto habra no
possibilità di le ray servizi de salir a
mode a lighted e di viaggio a bra no la
possibilità quinn de la compania de
pro-poor first aid yet the changes won't
take effect till twenty thirty three at
the earliest as Member States won the
battle to have long transition periods
for the rules to take effect